[Music]
no I can't
this guy had a whole shot cooter II
platter yeah like the crackers the the
little little pickles the cornichons
yeah there is it huh Darren's was it
both of y'all was he I just want we got
up and walked as uh it's weird his
Darius stepped to me I was on the on the
front porch and he was walking up I was
just about to go cuz I was like I saw
this kitchen there's the aisle I was
like man I'm gonna go cook some [ __ ] up
for the fellas sup man I've been into
cooking lately man yeah bruh I made some
st. Louis baby back pork ribs last week
lemon lemon encrusted salmon and just
like I think it's just from years even
stand up comedy feeling like I can't eat
it no more
yeah so I'm just like why not just eat
good so I was gonna get up and just go
shopping you know for everybody and just
cook and then I ran into him and we
ended up going to a wine and cheese
store we came back with champagne and
some brie like he it's like you read my
mind of all the things I loved just like
this [ __ ] came back with
champagne prosciutto brie cheese Cornish
owns those green olives yeah that's
hilarious because when I saw I was
gambling on that yeah but I think that's
Tony's influence up I thought you
would've first do to put me on to like
just like your guts your piece but just
like not having them just like when you
in the VIP somewhere is just like oh you
can just have a little snack kind of
[ __ ] well adult Lunchables yeah without
like [ __ ] eating Doritos and [ __ ]
like just stuff your [ __ ] up a little
bit it's only like three more dollars
just like don't eat shitty food no more
that game stopped eating shitty folks
yeah ma that was what you said about
cooking was because I was one of my
things this year was to try to just cook
more myself well I fell into it while I
was living in New York I fell into a
wild pattern where my apartment on Grand
Street in New York that I moved into at
the beginning of 2010 never cooked a
meal that it really never even an eight
at one point brought in a new stove
what's up I don't even know if that [ __ ]
worked for real they were like we order
bring a new stove this one hasn't been
turned off okay hook oh I never cook so
much just delivery and eating out and
just traveling all the time never cooked
in there's like what and it and once you
have the ingredients cooking take just
as long as wait look around yeah and
things you know what happened to it and
whatnot you hit it on the head you know
what happened to it's like my question
is this how often can you eat food
cooked by somebody that doesn't give a
[ __ ] about you before you get sick I
mean that's true
you can just feel it in your soul
doesn't give a [ __ ] here eat this burger
how many orders they dropped on ya yo I
got so mad when I ordered some Harold's
chicken on uber eats and then I look at
the do we pull up and he grabbed my
chicken out the trunk and I was like yo
what have some CDs for sale back there
my [ __ ] was in the trunk like the Harold
five minutes yeah it was in the backseat
goddamn Chicago institution [ __ ] you
well here's the question about when you
guys cook and [ __ ] it's really about the
way you do your grocery shopping like
how do you grow do you like get a week
worth the groceries or do you just get
groceries to cook for that night like
how do you usually grocery shop or for a
weekend or whatever I've been starting a
meal prep man in a little way you know
obviously I have more
it was scheduled now because of the show
but I'll get up in the morning I go to
the gym every morning and when I come
back out because I'm like I think it's
my first job I used to be a short-order
cook at Embassy Suites still like the
smell of eggs and sausage I love to cook
it for other people but I can't eat it
that smell does nothing for me toast and
almost [ __ ] you got that weird like it
wanted like I can't do it so I'll get up
and I'll just have salmon with an
arugula salad at like 10 o'clock in the
morning and that'll be my first meal and
then you know I have another like
smaller meal at like 1:30 but it's all
[ __ ] that I've cooked and prepped and
it's just like it's better I don't cray
I stop craving dumb [ __ ] I never want
like a Philly cheesesteak no more or
just like Wendy spite I don't want that
[ __ ] no more just like this should I
cook or should the like a better cook so
like what I know especially like you the
most class taking this dude I've ever
met you seem like you got cooking class
written all over you man I want I want
to take one when I was in in Thailand
but I was just but that's a you know
I'll see Airbnb experiences in different
places and that's usually you can in
different countries you can take a
cooking class with a local person but I
want to start doing that they say if you
can read you can cook which I'm just
sure I'm sure just part of that it's
true isn't it it doesn't apply to all
items this no you know what cooking is
like cooking is like fighting it's like
because I worked as a line cook before
excited for this metaphor yeah real talk
like you could look at recipes online
and you can make meals and you could
yeah you could do that anybody could do
that right but like to be able to like
just trigger from your brain muscle
memory like okay this is to cook like
this and everything has to come together
I just it was really about timing
cooking is about timing so it's like bam
bam bam everything's hot warm on the
plate ready to go
mm-hmm that takes training and that is
being on a line in a kitchen like when
it's like the middle of brunch and you
got to crank out [ __ ] 20 omelets at a
time
I would I used to a bit about that where
I would be in a diner cook when I would
yeah I would
have a breakdown as soon as somebody or
order that omelet and somebody else
ordered mac and cheese yes how it is bro
I gotta make an omelet in mac and C peas
out yeah this is too much for me you did
her gunshot go off in the kitchen yeah
no but you got no AC in the kitchen
nothing like you're under pressure and
so like that becomes just a way of life
so it's like fighting it's like you
could they could teach you how to kick
they could teach you how to punch but
you've never been into a fight that
[ __ ] who's never [ __ ] trained
but got into like a hundred fights is
gonna kick your ass probably most likely
yeah you know it's like how many times
have you been in the [ __ ] I would make
the argument that chefs and comics are
have very similar lifestyles and that we
don't do [ __ ] and then all of a sudden
500 people sit down and you got to serve
them at the same time and then it's over
and then you I mean you think about like
the late great Anthony Bourdain and his
issues with substance abuse and all that
kind of [ __ ]
I think it comes from the adrenaline
rush that comes from that that 8 o'clock
dinner rush that eight o'clock 10
o'clock show and then you trying to
figure out how do I come down from this
you either want to go up with more drugs
or you come down with booze or you come
down with girls or vice or whatever the
[ __ ] you do and it's kind of the similar
lifestyle you you're up late you eat and
wrong you drink it too much and that's
why chefs are tatted up and [ __ ] up
and the comics are tatted up and [ __ ]
up yeah I mean yeah that's thing that's
that you're right on the nose with that
yeah yeah some of your chef buddies be
kidding it they get it all the way but
then it's just like there's some about
like and I'm anxious to hear on the next
podcast like once you start cooking
there's some about this you forget that
there's like a tangible aspect of
cooking or just like seasoning I
remember talking to my mom Valerie who's
the best cook I've ever had ever tasted
and I was like how do you get your
chicken to taste like this and she goes
she was like baby I take each piece and
she seasons it by hand and she seasons
and you can taste it and it's like
doesn't taste like other things is
because that [ __ ] was made with love and
care it wasn't somebody that stoned out
a mine throwing some [ __ ] drumsticks
in a box yeah you know it's like
somebody's like I love you I'm cooking
this for you and you taste that [ __ ] in
her food right you know and that's like
I feel like in it almost kind of comes
back to what we were talking about
earlier we are passionate dudes let's be
a hundred percent with it and like
everything we do we go all-in
that's why Tony gave a [ __ ] about
soundcheck that's why you give a [ __ ]
about making sure the second show starts
on time and that [ __ ] transfers into his
DJing into your cooking into whatever
that [ __ ] all comes together because
like everything you do you're gonna do
it 100% so like do it for you stop
eating [ __ ] shitty food everybody
stop eating that [ __ ]
stop eating [ __ ] from a [ __ ] box
[ __ ] cook for yourself what phase it
out yeah you gonna tough to stop what's
your what's the one thing that every
once in a while you just crave coz me
it's Wendy spicy chicken sandwiches do
is every time I see a Popeyes I consider
popular yeah I don't eat it every time
but it's the only one out of the fast
foods well there's nothing quite what's
your order uh two piece of three piece
and then if if I'm he's for grouped in
one of the boxes and then I end up
eating more than you really like a two
or three piece is a filling meal but
then it was one I order a piece from
Harold stinking home I have a couple in
an e later and then there's a late
December 2017 and I ate it's just an
eight piece and once it you know who am
i there's eight eight pieces of fried
chicken with no weed before yeah without
the munch he's just straight up just
like cuz I wanted to and you know those
last two pieces you were just getting
them down you were done you were done at
six which you like I can't leave a piece
and then one with two bites out of it so
now you've got a
my uncle came by the crib I like I have
to cover back-to-back days of Harold and
he saw the boxes and [ __ ] it was just
yelling at me he's like what is this
[ __ ] man like he found empty babies yeah
it was like that it was like he found
his [ __ ] what are you doing you call it
to order again they like hold on the
manager comes on the phone Hannibal what
are you doing yeah right yeah I so I
went to the store before here at a gas
station and just bought some beverages
and stuff for the UH for the place for
the air B&B it's a beautiful home nice I
bought some weed tests some I don't know
why impulse buys dog still you know I
had to work on they had those at the gas
station yeah anybody want to take a drug
test of marijuana test I'll take one
it's gonna be a waste cause it's gonna
come positive for what if I don't know
if mine what if it comes negative and
then we [ __ ] blast this company for
consumer fraud Podcast Better Business
Bureau
comes up negative I'll be super
surprised you want to take you wanna
take it
alright I'll grab the judge says well
how do you take tests you gotta piss on
Edison I'm assuming you yell at it I
swear to God I didn't do it get the
sword at home marijuana drug test
easy-to-use
Colet urine in a clean cup yes you gotta
piss doesn't contaminate oh yeah the
heroin addict you
I hope I hope whoever's house this is
doesn't watch our podcast they like was
glad that they PA answer all of them
so yeah before you'd says three things
doesn't have a watch clock or with a
second hand or timer available collect
urine in a clean cover move the test
strip from the seal pouch immerse the
strip into the urine with the arrow
pointing towards the urine take the
strip out after a minimum of 10-15
seconds they just reflect on a clean dry
non absorbent surface read results in
five minutes do not read results after
more than five minutes what the [ __ ]
type of test is this [ __ ] self
destructs here's a white woman letting a
dog [ __ ] in the yard word hey for real
yeah conversation wait she's old be cool
all right all right there at narrate
this all right Hannibal's up he's
looking now he's stepping out to make
sure that there's no dog [ __ ] I didn't
see her bend over to clean up with maybe
just a piss she just she looking around
like wait he just he just confronted her
he's good friend he's asking a woman if
her dog just [ __ ] this woman's black man
in 17 years and now a black dude that
looks like she oh she said she got it
she said she got it okay now she's just
a sweet old yes all right we assume the
worst out of people warmer in Florida
yeah I feel bad laughter I just so don't
feel bad you know how many don't feel
bad about the roles being reversed you
know how many black dudes they weren't
doing [ __ ] the police on who switched it
up [ __ ] new black money in his [ __ ]
35 got dope confront Oh white ladies
with their dogs what's up Florida it's
the new floor because the perspective I
had was like I see but I can see your
finger pointing through the window that
how you dressed her hey lady I say hey
is your dog [ __ ] this you like I can't
hear you oh I can't hear you because I
don't project well we got bags
she said bags all right good and then
she was weirded out cause she saw Yvonne
with the camera right over my shoulder
like what's going on some Franco but
yeah you know that dog was marinating
for a while that was a no black man
would have been allowed to stand in
front put somebody's property at all
with that dog you know you know sweaty I
got a buddy back home who who brings the
bags and everything but he hates picking
up [ __ ] so every time his dog shits he
pretends like he's picking up with a bag
and everything but he doesn't do I
notice buddy no no no try to guess out
of
Oh Fred but come I can't have a dog if
you don't want to pick the [ __ ] up
that's yeah that's one a to having a dog
is yeah you're invested in 15 years of
picking up dog [ __ ] yes yeah yeah yeah
and you have to feed it here that's
that's why I don't have a dog is the
walk like the [ __ ] schedule part because
they eatin and hanging out that seems
fun you all can eat while you eat and
just hang out and teach it tricks and
all that stuff you can create an
Instagram account for the dog you're
gonna monetize the dog make it
merchandise all that's there you just
don't want to deal with the
responsibility of the dog and that's
also you know I say that without having
one but then I wonder if this is one of
those things if you get it then you like
always worth this it's worth it - what -
it depends on where you live and
obviously you're a man of international
travel you could live kind of wherever
you want to but you got a factor that
[ __ ] in if you live in anywhere where it
gets cold yeah for four months out of
the year when it's when it's 11 degrees
yeah and the dogs at the door and you're
in your underwear warm do you want to
throw your [ __ ] on and go outside
probably not now if you do I don't get a
dog you do I mean you you yeah yeah but
it's a decision you need to make before
you get a dog I'm glad you thought that
[ __ ] out I mean no I didn't even think
that I was just like sometimes man when
it's cold as [ __ ] you like you don't
leave the crib like by the way that old
ladies cross the street on the other
side of the street Westside strong side
she's so thrown off especially with
these houses over here going in - yeah
yeah yeah Oh folks homes are different
now that I think because people live
longer now is like I think back in the
day all folks I was like where you want
to die but now you go and you like I'm
starting my new life on 56 you an active
living center you with 56
55-plus is when you can move in but why
is that like like you mean like the old
people apartment building or like 55
that's like you still yeah you're still
yes but like psycho you could Gregg
Popovich's older than that I know but
Gregg just killing in life okay let's
say you look like Craig Gregg poppers
you not him do you want to struggle
through life or you want to be the new
young buck at the Senior Living Center
you go in there ball out of control and
go take some dudes girls just wheel them
away be like hey this is my girl now d6
is pretty early 55 Plus Michael is it
not 55 plus senior living center in
because everything is 55 plus like the
menu at Denny's I pull up a Senior
Living Center no discounts yet no that's
not even discount they say only for like
a [ __ ] it's now man 55 55 five
years over the hill that [ __ ] two years
from 70 yeah I'm four since I'm putting
early bird special age and okay cuz I
all right fit no 55 is young but [ __ ]
what if this is how we found out out was
a robot this entire time this is only
this is the holy malfunction where take
10% off your shed a few 55 well
killing it at Denny's that's Denny's
early bird special yeah I don't want to
get into your triple a discount okay so
alright use you support it to a point
that is young yeah my dad is 66 yeah
yeah about the turn 67 and he's yeah
yeah I just think I think just people
think about we've been talking about
food and everything I just think people
take better care of themselves people
ain't smoking you're gonna drink like
that their whole life people eat better
and so like I just think at 55 you like
you getting ready to start a second
probably retired and starting a new
career yeah better retirement oh you are
I saw you have the new podcasts going
I do man thanks for bringing that up man
yeah me and the homie Frank Caliendo
yeah we started a podcast we we do a
radio show called a Bob and Tom show and
we met at our at our Radio affiliate
whatever we hit it off and I kind of
like talking to him cuz he's uh he's
conservative without being crazy and I
remember talking it means like man I
live my life and services you know he's
like I've never had you know been drunk
I don't he just like he's a conservative
dude and he throws money around right
and so like I was just interested in
bringing dialogue with somebody like
myself that's obviously more
left-leaning with somebody that's
conservative but not a nutcase because I
do think that there are still
conservatives that like their
conversations we can have like do you
think you know sex ed should be taught
in school or clean needle programs you
can we can have that discussion you know
but it's just like when it starts
leaning in towards the taking kids away
and all that's when it gets out of
control so I just wanted to bring back
like normal dialogue plus he's hilarious
he does all the impressions so yeah it's
fun and fun and kind of real at the same
time so we'll see first episodes up Alan
Frank trying to be serious check us out
dope [ __ ] all right al Jackson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]